[Applause]
hey you made it
actually yes we did
well there were a lot of them but you
did great come on let's see what's
hiding in here besides hordes and hordes
of frozen hive I mean destiny too has
been struggling to keep its players
invested for a while now
going into its second expansion war mind
the biggest question was whether or not
destiny 2 can entice people to come back
to it this expansion is geared more
toward the hardcore players offering
difficult endgame activities and a
slower more demanding level grind to get
there if you aren't interested in those
things though there's not a lot here
besides the same old destiny 2
activities to draw you in war Mayans
campaign takes around an hour and a half
to complete if you haven't played
destiny too much since cursive Osiris
it's easy to jump back in I started at
310 power and did some minimal grinding
to keep up with each missions
recommended level it remains a very
welcome change from Destiny's more
punishing pace we're skipping a few
weeks meant another few weeks of intense
grinding just to catch up like most
story centric activities in destiny -
war mines campaign does just enough
explaining to justify fighting enemies
in the first place and leaves you to
fill in the rest yourself that can work
really well but in war mind a lot of
seemingly important things are packed
into a very short amount of time a
buried Golden Age research facility new
information about rest footin a crazy
powerful spear and suddenly a giant worm
that you have to kill it's not that
those things aren't connected but rather
that there's no time to absorb anything
before you're in the final fight and
it's anticlimactic as a result
I knew you'd steal Guardian
couldn't have done it without you Anna
thanks for the assistant a part where
mines different components are actually
kind of cool the Valkyrie spear can take
out swarms of enemies in one very
satisfying throw and fighting a huge
serpentine monster is fun just for the
spectacle of it the new ally character
and a Bray is almost interesting she's
related to Clovis Bray a figure in
destiny lore and can speak to Rasputin
but she doesn't have enough time to
develop into anything substantial the
warmind is an expansion about a
hyper-intelligent
AI that's been around since the first
game it feels like these are just the
building blocks for what could be a
compelling story
I am rasputin's guardian of all I survey
I have no equal for more laid-back
destiny to players the more accessible
activities are a great way to test out
the new exotic weapon changes that
launched alongside the expansion the
one-point 2.0 update is available even
if you don't have war mind but it's at
least nice to have a reason to try out
the exotic buffs my personal favorites
are the graviton Lance which now fires a
two-round burst with a heftier and more
satisfying explosion on impact and risk
runner which deals more damage when its
art conductor buff is active they
actually feel like true exotics now and
as a result our loot worth chasing so
much so that the changes kind of steel
war mines thunder
two of our minds story missions are
disappointingly repurposed as strikes
just like in cursive Osiris the addition
of nightfall like modifiers to heroic
strikes makes them a lot more difficult
at least but the loot chests reward for
completing them doesn't match the
challenge weapons and gear drop at 3:40
power which is right about where you'll
be when you finish the story the new cap
is 385 leaving a large gap between the
easy content and the in-game that could
have been filled with mid tier heroic
strike rewards as a whole the mid-level
section of the expansion is
unfortunately pretty empty of anything
to motivate you to keep going forward
the new destination the polar ice caps
of Mars is around the size of IO in
addition to new adventures in lost
sectors Mars also boasts a new activity
called escalation protocol it works kind
of like a public event in that anyone in
the area can join but it's way harder
throwing waves of high-level hive at you
as of week one it's basically impossible
to complete it which makes it a nice
accomplishment to chase if you've been
wanting more to do in the late game so
far escalation protocol is the most
intriguing thing in war mind I actually
want to level up enough so I can see
what happens and what kind of loot I can
get
it certainly feels like warmind has a
slower burn than vanilla destiny - or
cursive Osiris in order to get the
exotic fusion rifle sleeper stimulant
for example you have to complete a time
intensive multi-step quest that involves
running both heroic strikes and
escalation protocols on the most
hardcore end of things the challenging
new raid lair is a big incentive to get
your power level up the grinding alone
will likely keep the most dedicated
players busy for a bit and figuring out
and implementing a viable strategy once
you actually make it to the raid layer
is as always a reward in itself for a
lot of players though much of the
process of getting to that high-level
amounts to busy work if you aren't
already dedicated to reaching the level
cap and completing every late-game
activity where mine doesn't offer many
draws for you the only reason to do
anything is to level up or get new loot
and that can keep you busy for a while
this time around how busy depends on
your patients when grinding and your
desire to jump through every hoop to get
there that Baron middle tier when you've
beaten the story and need to grind 20 or
30 levels so you can reach the endgame
is a very easy place to lose steam you
don't understand the connection I share
with Rasputin's here let me show you
[Music]
okay we should really figure out exactly
what's doing that